but first my sauce at the end of day 44
America in shutdown now remember back in
March when New York Governor Andrew
Cuomo gave this very ominous warning we
are your future where we are today you
will be in three weeks or four weeks
well that forecastle isn't even close
there have been twenty 3384 deaths in
the Empire State as of this evening
meaning the death rate there is a
hundred and twenty per 100,000 the next
highest death rate in kovat is New
Jersey with 6771 Cova deaths or 73 per
hundred thousand now New York is and
always was in its own category of
coronavirus suffering and they did
suffer and continue to but it's
certainly not like Florida which locked
down later than most states and is now
reopening earlier everyone in the media
was saying Florida was going to be like
New York or Italy and that has not
happened because we understood we have a
big diverse state I have less than 500
people at a state of twenty-two million
on ventilators as of last night and I
have six thousand in five hundred
ventilators that are sitting idle so
it's worth asking why are states with
far less severe outbreak states that
happen to be run by Democrat governors
and/or blue state governors like
Virginia and North Carolina
why are those still under strict
lockdown measures well they claim
they're following data
so let's actually look at the data
Virginia's death rate is 20 times less
than New York's at just six per hundred
thousand for a total of 522 Virginians
lost their life to Cove it of course
every life lost is heartbreaking it is
tragic there is no doubt about it but
what about the Virginia lives lost due
due to skyrocketing unemployment or
increasing substance abuse mental
illness domestic abuse Georgia in
Florida which are both headed by
conservative governors we know are
already open
they're taking a whole of state approach
to the situation and receiving non-stop
criticism from the left for doing so
well the angle warned you weeks ago
weeks ago that liberals would try to
keep their states locked down as long as
possible whatever their actual kovat
numbers were regardless of the economic
karmic carnage this was causing now
Virginia Governor Ralph Northam is
really in a category of his own he wants
to reopen as slowly as possible we need
to see the percentage of positive tests
and the number of hospitalizations both
tracked downward over 14 days enough
capacity in our hospital beds we need to
sustain our PPE supply we cannot and
will not lift restrictions the way you
turn on a light switch the numbers in
Virginia are low they're among the
lowest in the country now North Carolina
is even a lower Cova death rate three
per hundred thousand which is 40 times
less than New York's death rate of
course Democrat governor Roy Cooper
there was unmoved by the data and last
week he extended his state's locked down
until May 8 makes no sense well North
Carolinians didn't take kindly to that
protesters storm the State Capitol
yesterday to demand that Cooper rescind
his stay at home order well what did the
state do the state responded by
arresting four of them including an
organizer for merely stepping onto the
sidewalk outside the governor's mansion
I kid you not my question is where's the
media now the first thing I'm gonna
exist to do what to ensure that we the
people retain our right not to just say
stuff that people agree with but to
speak out against the powerful and
especially our politician this whole
point isn't it or does our press believe
that free speech is only worth
protecting if it supports issues they
like like gun control women's rights
climate change well the truth is this
kovat crisis has exposed the American
media
for what they are these people are
control freaks now check out this
headline from CNN the article says China
despite being where the virus first
emerged has coped with the ensuing
pandemic far better than many other
countries
the article goes on to tout the quote
benefits of a strong government and
centralized planning while exposing the
limitations of private industry to
respond quickly particularly in the
healthcare sector since a centralized
planning and limitations of private
industry I'm gonna translate that for
you
communism good capitalism evil that's
shorthand now in authoritarian regimes
the elites don't serve the working
people we know that right they rule over
them social control over large
populations is achieved through fear and
intimidation and suppression of free
thought conditioning the public through
propaganda is also key new dogmas
replace good old-fashioned common sense
the advice from the experts is clear
wear a mask for the protection of other
people if the Vice President chose not
to you should have worn a mask today I
mean that there's no question I did wear
a mask to protect the community maybe
Mike Pence just wants to catch it
already and be put out of his misery
those are nice nice people
well it's Chris Cuomo wearing a mask out
on the Hamptons the other weekend off
maybe well by the way they'll say this
whole mass thing is settled science just
like they do with climate change of
course it's not and they know it our own
experts have gone from masks aren't
necessary to masks are essential you
have to wear them when you go jogging in
just a few weeks time now rush limbaugh
made a great point as he always does on
the radio the other day and he said the
virus itself as it weakens and states
start reopening the media that have been
selling this panic panic panic for weeks
and weeks and weeks they have fewer
images to sell their hysteria to justify
continued lockdowns but the masks well
they're kind of a
constant reminder you see the mast
anything you're not safe you are not
back to normal not even close
well enter dr. foutch II it's not gonna
disappear from the planet which means as
we get into next season in my mind it's
inevitable that we will have a return of
the virus or maybe it never even went
away but on what scientific basis is he
saying this is it settled science that
this corona virus will come back for
sure in the fall no it's not settled
science here's a totally different view
from Frances preeminent infectious
disease expert professor Didier Raoul
this curve is called a bell curve this
is the typical curve for epidemics most
of the time it goes like this
so the rebound story is a fantasy that
was invented based on the Spanish flu
which started in the summer and
therefore has nothing to do with this
epidemics begin they accelerate they
culminate this is the moment of maximum
transmissibility and then they decrease
and they simply disappear and we don't
know why remember the last bad
coronavirus we dealt with was SARS it
started in November and it ended in July
now why aren't any media types here
questioning doctor foul cheese
assertions no disrespecting his amazing
experience and all the work he's done
but that's quite an assertion and it
spreads absolute fear in panic and why
isn't any good news in this fight
against the corona virus ever taken to
heart it's usually dismissed usually by
a lot of the experts in most of the blue
state governors well the answer isn't
based in science or good journalism
perhaps so the only answer is that
election year politics is trumping
practical thinking and perhaps even
trumping real science now that is a
national tragedy if that is the case and
those are my thoughts at the end of day
40 for America and shut down